cheapest house in the UK purchased it
for 38,000 hang on bought it for
38,000 I didn't even know houses existed
in the UK that were that cheap the G had
been living in it hadn't treated it
right hadn't used a bathroom for years
lovely it was do you think it was the
cheapest proper in the UK what on right
movie it was they had poo all over it
basically
yeah really good to have you on the show
Daman thanks for having me you've been
in construction now for 12 years 12
years and in the last couple years
you've blown up your property business y
absolutely millionaire yep making
passive income of over 10 grand a month
yep so I want to pick your brain and
find out how you've done it and how
you've managed to scout your your your
business so firstly what was it that got
you into property investment in the
first place yeah I started off about
about 18 months ago I I looked at a
property I thought it was a bit of money
to be made didn't really understand um
the strategies that were available and
the ways of doing it all but when they
seeing the property no can make some
money purchased it renovated it but I
purchased on a mortgage and I got to the
end and and sort of made a bit of money
and I sort of said to me for I and do
I've known for years and years you know
come and have a look and he came down he
said yeah brilliant what you doing now I
said well got to wait a while till I
remortgage it he said what do you mean
remortgage it I said well you I don't
own it I I own it through a mortgage so
he then sort of said well look next time
you know moving forward you need to go
meet my mate Samuel um he'll get you in
the academy he'll uh he'll teach you out
to do it properly anywhere from there
really he's a good friend yes I mean the
fact that he pushed you to me he
obviously cared about you yeah and Scott
anyone doesn't know him he's also been
on winners on a Wednesday he did the
Academy I think it was like 2019 when he
did the academy so when we met and you
went through the training what was the
first deal that you did because you've
done lease options you've done rent to
rents you've done buy refurbisher
Finance um what was the first deal that
you did whilst I was sort of in the
process of signing up for the Academy I
did one with Scott so that one aside the
first one I did sort of after doing the
BR course um was a property in
Gainesboro uh purchased it for 38,000
did a 20,000 run renovation jeez it got
revalued at 100 so pulled out 75,000
hang on hang on you bought it for
38,000 y I didn't even know houses
existed in the UK that were that cheap
the one thing that that the academy
taught me is that you know you should
never stop stop Trying stop looking for
something even if you're not in a
position necessarily straight away you
just never stop looking CU because good
things will come and I went to view the
property or I I rang to view a property
um in gainsboro and they said no but
look someone's just pulled out a deal
done if it's of interest but you've got
no time to view it you need to complete
within 8 days I can give you a video of
the property but that's it we got no
time to show you take it or leave it
it's got to be a cash purchase well send
me the video so I sent the video I
thought wow this is a mess I mean the
gentleman had been living in it hadn't
treated it right hadn't used the
bathroom for years he'd been using rooms
and lovely it was so it was it was real
real bad State and I think that's why
the other um other sort of party had
pulled out but either way SP list um I
asked a favor see if he'd he'd work over
the weekend check in the search packs if
I paid him a little bit extra and
whatever he's a good guy and yeah
essentially we got the deal completed in
in four working days you know what that
shows as well the power in business have
been able to make quick decisions you
have to be a quick decision maker if
you're a faffer in in in the property
game you ain't going to get anything
done they are they are and every time
you find something decent if you're well
let me just think about it let me speak
to my wife and my lawyer and my dog and
let me pray about it Deal's gone so you
move fast on that yeah yeah well it was
a it was a case that there was a a third
party company where uh recovering debts
that were owed by the gentleman who were
selling the property and they' basically
sort said look I'm getting this amount
of money this is happening on this day
and so when when so they pulled out they
got go back to the market and
everybody's got to put bids in and it's
got to you know be competitive again and
the property Market at that point was
Rising so I'm thinking well it could be
an opportunity I have a look but at the
time I remember looking on on right
moving the cheapest property in this a
three bed this is a three bed terrist
the cheapest property in the whole of
the UK three bed in real real bad state
was 47 grand I thought well if I'm
buying the cheapest property in the UK
i' got to make money surely think it was
the cheapest property in the UK well on
right move it was on right move I
searched for right move three bed
properties even Leisa cheapest house in
the UK yep that had poo all over it
basically yeah and then renovated it how
much do you say the renovation was uh it
was just over 20 so in total that's like
about 58 59 Grand I think including
legals it was 60 60 grand for everything
and then you got it refinanced at 100 so
yeah we valued at 100 and pulled 75 out
so you didn't just pull out all your
money you pulled out all your money plus
15 grand tax free absolutely dude that
is the deal of deals where is it gainsb
gainsb yeah is it Ted now it's tented
yeah get 595 a month and what's the
mortgage payment uh 363 so have I love
that that I've not seen many deals as
good as that I've seen a few but that is
brilliant I to go visit that house yeah
absolutely we around that house so that
was the first one did you get a lot of
confidence from that yeah I to be fair
with my Construction Company I've been
sort of part of refurbs before so I sort
of understand the process and and you
know get it but the fact that I found it
myself yes I progressed in myself I mean
I hadn't I've only ever viewed the
property still to this day I've only
ever viewed it three times wow uh once
was when we'd gone back to Brick so he'
already gone back to Brick from from
purchase um once was once we when we
were sort of just finishing painting the
walls and then once was when I at a
letting agent there I've never been back
since employing people to do it and and
what te yeah that's it and it's just
yeah the deal was good but the thing is
though although it's a really banging
deal because it's so small there was
still only 40 Grand profit in it the net
percentage was really high but the
actual profit wasn't that High um not
knocking it because it a banger I'd buy
it but what have you done since then
have you into bigger deals now yeah so
the that was a JV with um with a close
friend of mine so our next project is is
purchasing a property for 73 and a half
so okay what I'm saying is we not put
any additional money in we're just
scaling up from from where we were yeah
because you just ped all your money out
so you're recycling it into the next
deal is have you bought that now um it
completes next week nice so what are the
figers on that one so it's 73 A2
purchase price the renovation will be
about 16 yeah now originally we thought
the gdv would be around 100 to 110 so
the deal well 110 to 120 but it is in a
place where we can do it as an essay no
six months in with full money out but
actually a property nine doors down has
gone up for sale and sold already um but
they that was so this is a twoed Terrace
sorry this is twoed Cottage um that's a
twoed terrist and that's just gone on
the market 167 and a half and it's
smaller than the cottage and yours is a
cottage and it's got parking so now I'm
thinking well if the G DV was even close
to what the Terrace property would be
where is that that one is in a small
Village North of skunthorp that's
beautiful so that that will probably
make you another sort of 60 70 grand
pull all your money out it will get more
than the money out as well yeah um and
when purchasing the property as well
they notice a little parcel of land
that's not been acquired so we've we
managed to acquire that with it as well
which we now can put a door out into
this part of land which on on the side
and we're going to have decking and a
hot tub there and everything beautiful
it's going to be really well done would
you reckon that will make a monthin cash
flow if do a service accommodation so
we've calculated to be about £2,400
profit at 70% occupancy wow that's like
replace the average salary for most
people just done that one deal yeah
that's it now the thing about you Damian
is you've basically done every strategy
so you've done service accommodation
lease options rent to rent have you got
a rent to rent yeah so I I only got my
first rent to rent two weeks ago still
in the grace period I'm still renovating
the property it's looking really good
now literally Furniture goes in next
week and then it's going to be it's
going to be launched but I just feel
that obviously you you pay the money for
the academy and and some people sort of
say you know well I'm thinking of this
I'm think I'm thinking you know what I'm
just going to do everything I'm going to
try everything I'm going to see what I
like see what I don't I want to make a
success out of every strategy so I can
have the sort of knowledge all around
because you never know what's around the
corner yeah you know iqu I've got four
lease options going through they go
through in two weeks that all came from
viewing a br commercial to residential
property then the lady asked to to meet
me and said you know I've got an issue I
need to sell this property I said look
it doesn't work for me but I met her you
know as a friend for advice really
because she was struggling with the
portfolio and it turns out that there
was only four properties really that
were causing her trouble with with sort
of negative cash flow and it put her in
a high tax ban sh hadow more in her name
so I met her with her as a friend at
Starbucks and met with her five times
she lives two hours away from me but I
just did it sort of for a bit of advice
um but then yeah it just so happened
that the that it opened up that the four
deals actually being a least option to
me and me worrying about the problem
tenants would yeah solve her problem if
it was a win-win rather than looking at
Le options as uh what you're getting oh
wow buy a house now and pay for it later
isn't that amazing yeah it is but I lot
of people say to me seems too good to be
true that's because they're not thinking
about the value that they're adding to
the other side it has to be a winwin
scenario so this lady then so how many
problem does she have in a whole
portfolio so her and her ex-husband have
a total of 18 right all completely
different apart from these four were was
similar to each other all four of them
um she purchased in 2008 and purchased
at market value then so now the
properties that that are worth about the
same amount as they were then wow it's
not even gone up in value in the last
sort of 15 years not at all and she's
she's out of a fixed term on a mortgage
so she can't remortgage these because a
lot of the mortgage companies are look
at her and saying well you're you're a
portfolio landlord so you know we won't
remortgage it and her financial
situation is changed and these are all
in her name so she's really struggling
remortgage them um therefore the
mortgage payments are pretty high
the tenants have got in there I mean one
of them completely trashed one of the
properties the the problem some of them
are problem telling tenants so so to her
they're they're
pains liabilities and once to take a tax
off she actually making a I think she's
making around 600 pound month loss on
the four jeez so how are you going to
make money from them then if you take
those bad horrible four properties off
of her I'm going to turn all four into
hmos right all I've been to all four the
layout's perfect um there's gonna be
three four bed and one six bed HMO jeez
nice um and I've agreed the purchase
price of of the figures that are roughly
what they worth now so the renovation
cost will be um I'll get that back
obviously when I purchase the properties
I've got five years on two and seven
years on the other two wow so I just
Stage IT purchase them when the
properties are worth enough to basically
put no money in and just and is that
they going to work legally as HMR
absolutely you've checked all the done
all the checks article four licensing
everything I know the licensing officer
we' checked the article 4 um I've got a
a HMO in the similar area I've just
checked everything I've spoke to um the
relevant people as well to make sure
there's demand for them and there
absolutely is there's there's several
agents that are wanting to take them off
their hands already so and from her
perspective she probably hasn't got the
inclination all the knowledge or the
energy all the time yeah I think it's
more I think it's more energy she's
she's um you know gone into it with the
energy but that's sort of she's tired
she's she's had enough and the great
thing with her as well is because this
started off as me just giving her advice
as a friendly advice as whatever else um
and she's now she she's inheriting some
money and um wants to do a project with
me to to basically foot Source it um
project manage it and we go 50/50 she
puts all the money in and do a JV as
well so that's awesome I think it it
just comes from being active you know
don't always look for what's in it for
me look what's in it for everyone the
thing is with property Damian is it's
it's quite a big pie so there's everyone
can make money the letting agent can
make good money the deal sourcer can
make good money if there is a deal
sorcer even the solicitors and the
Brokers you know the landlord the owner
that if you a rent to rent there's
there's enough money in the pie for
everybody to be able to make a piece and
if you're knowledgeable and valuable you
know you're in the construction
background so straight away bang if
you're doing a joint venture if I was
partnering with you and you find I'd be
thinking well he's he's in the
construction business he's going to be
to add a lot of value there so the more
valuable you can get the
negotiation the decisiveness the fact
that you were able to negotiate that
property for 30 what was it 38 grand
grand you know that's that's a skill um
the more you can bring to the table the
more valuable you are and then
ultimately value is followed by money so
how much are you making on average right
now then a month currently the
properties that we've got um we make
about £12,000 profit a month excellent
and where's the majority of that coming
from the majority of that is from a joy
Venture deal with a property that we we
basically purchased it with the
intention of converting it to an eight
bed eight on Suite HMO MH the property
is's not in terrible State it's livable
and whilst we're waiting for the
planning we we thought well it's it's
vacant we may as well sort of see if we
can you know offer something back and
and speak to some social housing um
places and sort of say you know do you
want any temporary accommodation and
yeah it got snapped up basically on a on
a deal which means that we don't need to
renovate it straight away now brilliant
and yeah it houses um people fleeing
domestic abuse situations um people
coming out of rehab rehab for various
things people s leaving hospital maybe
can't climb stairs so they need a
downstairs room and whatever else for a
few weeks so he sort of giving something
back and then they and they pay
generously as well so when did you buy
that property so acquired that one about
14 months ago and did you buy it or did
you control it we've purchased it on a
mortgage how much did you buy it for
purchased it for
152,00 why so specific because that's
what we buch it for that that's exactly
what we got 152 500 and on the day of
completion we we were toying between the
time sort of reselling it back on
because we knew the housing market was
booming and we sort of thought well free
somebody we won't that serious but we
thought we have a couple of estate
agents we know come around have a look
and they valued it at 250 so we got it
massively under Market negotiation King
so you bought it for 152 yeah and then
you got it revalued after you bought it
how long after on the day so we we've
got the keys at 11 and they came around
at 2 230 and 3 all three grand below
market value yep how did you get it so
cheap well it was it' been on the market
for a very long time um and we'd been to
meet the lady who was selling it on
behalf of a sister it sadly passed but
it just took so long going through like
we we put the offering in we put the
offer in and it completed 13 months
later and we knew within that year's
time the properties were increasing
value so we were a bit like I wonder
what it is worth you know cuz we thought
we'd got it under value under market
value anyway and I I wonder what it is
worth and a couple of properties on the
same sort of stretch of the road or
whatever else had had sold and and
they'd sold for a lot more and we
thinking well I think we' made a bit of
money here you know it's worth having a
look but yeah they came back at all all
of them valued the same as well that's
the power as well I know that wasn't a
least option but it while you were
waiting in those 13 months the seller
could have pulled out but a lease option
is where when you set the price now but
pay for it years down the line where the
seller can't pull out but you can
because you have the option you have an
option to buy not the obligation so so
100 Grand below market value you must
have been buzzing with that it was
really really pleased but if you bought
it for 152 Grand yep how much did how
you've not refurbed it yet we've done
part refurb how much you spent between
14 and 16 okay so you didn't couple of
boilers couple of flat roofs to where
the and how much are the social housing
paying for it um we we have average um
turnover from them about 12 Grand a
month 12 Grand a
month mate that's insane he started off
as gen genuinely being something we
thought you know what we can give
something back you know we've made our
money already we already had it valued
we already made a money that's just
ridiculous that's emergency that's it
yeah so it we do have spells where we
we're making a loss you know there's no
one in there or whatever else so okay it
is a high-risk strategy but it's one
that was lowrisk for us because we were
intending on it having it empty anyway
it was a case that we were waiting for
planning to go through um it was a six
bed property how does it work then
Damian help me out because normally the
deals that we've got where we pass it to
housing associations is they give us
just a flat guaranteed rent and then
they then make profit off the back of it
so they might pay us three four five
grand a month but it's guaranteed but it
sounds like that's not the case of this
one absolutely not no so we work almost
like the Overflow so they've got XY Z
number of properties that they they
House people in as priority but they had
too many people in these houses they
didn't want to take another one on long
term because their intention is to come
away from the strategy but they needed
someone short term you know and sort of
said to us can we just put these couple
of people in there for a couple of weeks
and then couple of weeks never ended so
how did you find them purely purely look
the the person who um was selling the
property they they basically had a
contact who had a contact who had a
contact and you just followed up the
lead yeah absolutely and and yeah he
just sort of went from there really and
now you know we we we've had opt options
to do sort of long-term long-term deals
with them as well what are you most
proud of that deal I think the the games
were one was the games were one I was
proud of because I sort of it was quick
decisions quick negotiation had to get
in there and then and then sort of I
purchased it I'm thinking have I missed
something here is there something wrong
so I was quite quite pleased with that
one what's your favorite strategy so far
then because you've done lease option
you've done rent to rent you've done
service accommodation you've done HMO
you've done social housing you've
basically done everything yeah I think
um I think the br's you know what is
what I know and a few Academy members
will message me regularly asking
questions and I love I love answering
them I love helping people out as well
um so the brr strategy but I think sort
brr to SA or BR to HMO is definitely the
way the way forward I did two brrs for a
standard sort of B to sort of exit and
whilst it's good it's sort of it never
really earns you the cash flow that you
want at the end so yeah I'm I'm sort of
for me I'm looking for things that are
going to give me good cash flow
afterwards going to keep passive income
increasing but that one deal you did
though where you bought it 100 Grand
below market value that's added 100
Grand to your net worth straight away
you do that 10 times you're a
millionaire absolutely you know I mean
it's not that not that hard becoming a
millionaire no stop I property is not I
agree how busy are you on your
construction business now have you
systemized that at all yeah so it's
quite systemized but I I also enjoy it
to a degree I've got my family work for
the business my friends work for the
business the business partner that's a
really good friend of mine as well so I
sort of enjoy still being part of it to
to a degree um so I'm working for I've
worked for roughly 30 to 40 hours in in
that business um a week right and I I
probably give about five hours a week to
a charity that I'm a a trustee for as
well that's good tell me about the
charity book that you do the charity
called Community wishes um they help
sort of disadvantage families and and
disadvantage and poorly children I
really enjoy it's it's not a massive
amount of time obviously don't get paid
I wouldn't want anything you know be fun
getting involved with the fundraising
getting involved in in the publicity for
the charity and stuff and just helping
out um in general I'd love to know more
we could donate to that as well that
that that sounds really good so what
would you say to people that are in
construction because I I meet a lot of
people that are in you know the building
trade industry they've got construction
businesses they're making decent amount
of money because there's decent money in
it but they really fancy themselves
actually buying the houses themselves
because it's quite from furiating I
think when you're constantly working on
other people's projects and you're
seeing how much money they're making and
you're kind of the worker that's it it's
a bit frustrating a lot of time people
want to go on the other side and join
the rich what would you say to people
trying to transition over to the other
side the first thing I learned was you
need to look at a property as though
you're paying a builder to do it even if
you're going to renovate it yourself um
you've got to look at the the figures as
though you are employing somebody else
to do it because you can very easily
fall into which I know a friend of mine
did fell into a trap of saying well I
can do this I can do that purchased the
property and all they did was tie all
their time up and made little profit
yeah cuz the deal wasn't good enough for
another investor who was going to pay
somebody else because it didn't stack
yeah so I think the first thing I'd say
is is just make sure that the deal is
right but I honestly can't uh promote
the the academy enough because for me
like looking back at my first deal it
was in swaddling coat purchased the
property for 147 spent about 20 on it
and yes okay it's worth 200k now but my
money still still tied up to this day
I've done all these other deals and I
refinance it next May and I'm like oh
great I'll finally get my money out you
know it would take me far too long to
become you know financially free or or
wealthy doing it that way you know it's
amazing the little things some of the
little things that you teach how
important they are later on in the
journey as well and he sort of sticks
with you and and just being surrounded
by the right people you know these
people are successful people they've
done it they've been there they'll all
assist each other and it's really
important to get educated on the right
way doing it on property just like you
would have done with the construction
yeah yeah did you come down to a crash
course yeah started a crash what did you
think when you came to a crash when you
came to the first crash course what
happened yeah I just I learned I learned
so much in that course and and I always
was going to sign up for the the um BR
of course because that's where I wanted
to sort of learn but there was no way I
weren't doing the academy then you know
I sort of I was in I was 100% in and
really enjoyed it the funny thing is
because like over a crash course it's
only one day but I want to teach so much
but I know if I just teach teach teach
teach teach a lot of the information
will get lost so that's why we do like
every every like half an hour I say turn
you give them a high five just changes
the energy and it changes what will be
your um best lessons that you've learned
then over the last sort of 18 months of
building up your portfolio I think you
know don't don't take any situation for
granted you know I've been to view a br
and come out with four lease options
I've been to or or should say been to a
br come out with nothing and then been
to um just just help someone came out
with four lease options I've been I
purchased a property to do a br to HMO
and ended up renting to social housing
I've been in so many weird and wonderful
yeah so situations like like you know
purchasing a property from a video on my
phone it was like what are you doing and
my sister is like what are you doing I'm
not buying it yeah yeah I don't I think
I just think don't take anything for
granted you know educate yourself get
yourself knowledgeable get yourself
open-minded you know stop thinking of
the negatives just think of a way of
making it work and and uh and then just
go for it I love that and I love what
you say as well about being open with
different strategies you ended up going
for a br and then it turns into least
options you end up going for a HA mer up
to Housing Association people say to me
what's the best strategy and I say there
isn't one you need to just become
well-rounded and learn as much as you
can and then just go out there and say
right what's most suitable for this you
know it's like uh if I'm speaking to an
estate agent I'll say what you got for
me I'll pass me something and I'll be
thinking could it work as a h and no
maybe not could it work as this and
you've got to be well-rounded yeah abely
and um I'm really proud of what you've
achieved it's great to have you on the
academy and thank you so much for coming
on the show thank you
[Music]
cheers